The Netflix roster of Marvel shows has already
shown that they're capable of drawing some
great moments from the comics and transferring
them to the screen.
And with the Punisher, they're spoiled for
choice.
With hundreds of comics and decades of stories
to draw from, all built around hard-hitting
ultra-violent action, there are plenty of
brutal moments that are begging to be recreated.
There is, however, a problem unique to the
Punisher: a lot of his stories might just
be too intense to work on the show.
And more are just intensely weird.
And yes — they're actually weirder than
this:
Here are some Punisher comic book moments
that'll never make it to Netflix.
Army of One
It goes without saying that any media project
involving Frank Castle is going to draw heavily
from Garth Ennis's eight years of writing
the character.
The Netflix shows have already started, with
an adaptation of the issue where the Punisher
ties Daredevil up to witness a rooftop execution.
But over the course of those eight years,
Ennis got into some pretty extreme stories.
In "Army of One," the Punisher took on an
entire island full of killer mercenaries,
including his long-time nemesis, the Russian,
who we've seen in the 2004 Punisher movie:
So why's the story so problematic?
Well, it's Frank's solution that causes trouble:
going for the nuclear option — literally.
The story ends with a mushroom cloud when
the Punisher drops an atomic bomb onto the
island and its mercenary inhabitants, wiping
them all from the face of the Earth.
Crackdown
Considering that the shows have already introduced
Luke Cage, it's easy to imagine that they
might want to tie the Punisher into the MCU
by re-creating one of their classic team-ups.
Unfortunately, their most notable meeting
involves Frank Castle changing his skin color
and pretending to be a black man for three
issues until he eventually fades back to his
usual Caucasian complexion.
In "Crackdown," Frank is sent to jail and
gets his face carved up by the bad guy Jigsaw.
After that, we see Frank's face get repaired
by a surgeon, whose experimental technique
involved pumping the Punisher full of the
skin pigment melanin.
The result was a dark-skinned, and ridiculously
inappropriate Punisher, who teams up with
Luke Cage in Chicago to bring down a ring
of crack dealers — and an army of ninjas.
Needless to say, after three issues, this
whole thing was never mentioned again.
FrankenCastle
Believe it or not, the tale of the temporarily
black Frank Castle isn't actually the weirdest
Punisher story — and neither is the time
he became an angel who killed demons with
magical ghost guns.
No, that honor goes to when he spent a year
as a Frankenstein.
In 2009, the notorious supervillain Norman
Osborn — better known to Spider-Man fans
as the Green Goblin — was put in charge
of national security.
An unrepentant murderer in a position of power
made for a tempting target, and Frank set
his sights on taking Osborn down.
The problem?
Frank's just a guy with a lot of guns — and
Osborn had his own team of Dark Avengers protecting
him.
Daken, the son of Wolverine, ended up chopping
the Punisher to pieces and throwing his body
into a sewer… where it was found and stitched
back together by Morbius the Living Vampire,
who resurrected him to protect a secret city
of monsters underneath Manhattan.
Chances are good that won't happen on TV anytime
soon: even if Jon Bernthal would look pretty
great as a Frankenstein.
Punisher kills Nick Fury
If they really wanted to tie Bernthal's version
of the Punisher to the larger Marvel Cinematic
Universe, they could always go with one of
Frank's other big encounters with the MCU's
most prominent characters.
Like that time he murdered Nick Fury.
In 1995, the Punisher was captured by renegade
S.H.I.E.L.D. agents and brainwashed into believing
that it was actually Fury who killed his family
— so he shot and killed him.
After a manhunt involving the Avengers, he
was arrested and sentenced to death in the
electric chair.
Because it's comics, neither death really
lasted long.
It was later revealed that Tony Stark had
invented a special "Life Model Decoy" robot
that managed to fool everyone.
And the Punisher?
He was rescued from the electric chair by
a mafioso who wanted him to take over his
organization.
He actually agreed, and briefly joined up
as the new head of an organized crime family.
Frank's hydrophobia
In the pages of Punisher War Journal, we finally
discover the Punisher's a weakness: a crippling
fear of open water, dating back to a childhood
trauma — because what the Punisher really
needed was to have a more traumatic past.
When Frank found himself tracking down a gang
of drug dealers to Hawaii, his fear almost
got him killed.
Luckily, he was rescued from drowning by a
friendly dolphin and then conquered his fear
with the help of a local kahuna who healed
his spirit with magic at the request of a
ninja master.
No, really.
Even if it's unlikely we'll ever see this
story make it to the screen, let's not kid
ourselves.
It would be amazing.
Who wouldn't want to see Frank Castle wearing
a bright Hawaiian shirt over his Punisher
outfit, or watch the Punisher ride a jet-ski?
The cover blurb says it all: "You just rented
a jet-ski to the Punisher.
KISS THAT BABY GOODBYE!"
Punisher Meets Archie
If there's a hall of fame for bizarre comic
book crossovers, then The Punisher Meets Archie
is a first-round pick.
Originally published in 1994, it stands as
one of the weirdest of all time, even after
a decade of Archie meeting everyone from Barack
Obama and Sarah Palin, to the Predator, to
Sharknado.
Yes, that Sharknado.
But incredibly, this team-up is actually more
plausible than ever.
On TV's Riverdale, a show with no shortage
of murders, the Archie gang's gone through
a pretty dark re-imagining.
So having Frank Castle roll up to lay down
some vigilante justice wouldn't seem strange
at all.
Is it going to happen?
No.
But if we don't at least get a cameo appearance
from Archie-actor K.J.
Apa as a redheaded criminal on the run from
the Punisher, then what are we even doing
here?
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this other cool stuff we
know you'll love too!